If you died, came back to life
and now you're forced to hunt aliens
in a real life death game.
What would you do?
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made, what you should do
and how to be the aliens in dance.
Kei is your typical high school student,
and he's going to die.
He's self-centered as hell
and has embarrassingly
high levels of testosterone.
He goes through the usual humdrum
life of school and on the way home decides
to take the metro.
But that was his biggest mistake and one
that will cost him dearly at the metro.
He meets this old fossil of a lady
who asks for directions just as he sees
his old classmate selfless Kato.
Suddenly, this drunken fool falls
down onto the track and nobody tries
to help him.
Kei has no interest,
but Kato rushes to save him
and struggles to lift him off of the track
just as he spots Kei.
He drags Kei down onto the track
through some good old fashioned
high school awkwardness.
The boys
then managed to help the homeless man,
but now the train is barreling down
towards them and they can't get back up,
so they start to run. OK?
This is absolutely horrifying.
Kato may have played the hero card
without thinking,
but is exactly this kind of recklessness
that is going to cost him big.
The two boys are lucky that they both
had the strength
to carry that bomb over the platform,
but that was risky, like the same reason
why they advise adults to put on
oxygen masks first before
putting it on their child in an airplane.
You can't help someone
if you can't help yourself first.
It's noted that trains have an average
speed of between 125 to 200 miles
per hour, with the latter
end of the spectrum
being more commonly found
within the trains in Japan.
However, like all trains,
a decrease in speed is needed
before a full stop at a station.
This is why it is safe to assume
that Kato or Kei could have instead
ran towards the tunnel
where the train was coming from
and get the attention of the operator
sooner
as the train would have already been
in a gradual state
of decreasing and speed, meaning
there was a higher chance for the train
to stop earlier
before it ran over that bomb on the track.
This was the most obvious method
of saving that fuel.
Trying to outrun the train
by running to the opposite
end of the tunnel
was really their only option
once they were on the tracks.
Despite how movies make it seem
because movie magic ducking under a train
while theoretically possible
is extremely unlikely and one that would
likely lead to a gruesome death.
I'd say that bomb had a good life,
and if it wasn't good,
then will hey, sucks to be him
all the more reason to die an early death.
The two boys
run for their life, begging to be spared,
but Mother Nature is one cruel mistress.
As the train catches up to them
and kills them,
it decapitates them right
then and there, with their lifeless
heads plopping right into the rows
of horrified passengers
who witness the gruesome event
suddenly can Kato end up
in a strange apartment room.
No pain, no nothing.
As their bodies are completely normal.
Something seriously
freaky is going on as they notice
more people already in the room
staring back at them.
And right in the middle of the room
stands a ginormous black sphere,
and it sits there
menacingly across from them.
Little do they know that this black sphere
will change their lives forever.
K demands to know what's going on
and asks around the mysterious room
if anyone has any idea
and to add to the scariness.
The look out the window to see Tokyo Tower
but can't for the life of them, open
the balcony doors.
It's almost as if they're ghosts.
This scares the hell out of them
as they try to scream and find out
just what the hell is going on.
But unfortunately for them,
no one can hear them scream,
nor can they call for help as their phones
don't work.
They're trapped in this room,
and no one is coming to save them.
They then find out from the silent crowd
who look back in amusement at the two boys
that everybody here is here for a reason
and that they all came here after dying,
horrible deaths, dying and reappearing
in this very room in various ways
with no memory of how they got there.
Kei then freaks out who gets mad at Kato,
whose goody two shoes
niceness got them both killed.
OK, if I was suddenly in a room
after being at a train station
seconds earlier,
this would have obviously meant
that something was up.
We have no idea what's going on.
We could have observed by everyone
telling us
that everyone came here after dying,
which means that this is likely
what just happened to us,
even if this fact
feels like something out of a science
fiction novel.
Now, I'm no astrophysicist,
but it's safe to say that
what just happened
isn't part of what we know
about the universe in general.
We're experiencing something alien
like that's happening to us,
especially if we can't touch or interact
with a windows or balcony doors
and knowing where we just came from,
for example, lying dead under the tracks .
This makes me suspect that either
we're in heaven, hell
or some form of purgatory,
and we're probably in for something
far more sinister.
Our only move here
is to gather as much valuable information
that we can from everyone here.
I get everyone to start yapping away
so I can find out enough details
and hopefully find some correlations
between their stories.
Because as much as I hate it,
no one can hear our screams,
meaning these strangers are our best bet
and staying alive
or whatever
the hell we are at this moment.
All of a sudden, a new member pops
up in the room, with everybody else
appearing through a laser
projection, slowly
coming into existence from thin air.
This naked redhead girl
then plops down into Kei's lap
as he gets excited and horrified,
but mostly excited as people around him
think he's a full blown creep.
I would agree with that, but this group?
Isn't playing around as this Yakuza
member groups are unconscious, naked body
and dragged her into the hallway
for some happy time.
Everybody is scared shitless
and no one bats an eye,
forcing Kato to play the hero card
yet again and go save her.
But he doesn't realize that this hero
complex will cost him his life very soon.
Kato then gets in between the Yakuza man
and red haired girl
as he tries to choke him.
Then, all of a sudden,
a horrifying
sound rings out throughout the whole room,
interrupting everyone
and summoning them
back into the other room.
It's the black sphere.
A message then is displayed on the screen,
saying Your lives are now over.
What you do with their new lives
is for me to decide.
This creepy haired kid
then says that the Black Spheres
name is Gantz and mentions
that no one is getting out alive.
Gantz
then writes another message on the screen,
showing a type of monster
with these traits
and abilities shown
for all to see, implying
that this is some kind of a terrifying
game.
Gantz suddenly opens up,
revealing an arsenal of high tech weapons
designed to kill and also reveals
a strange man inside the Gantz machine.
He then finds a case with his name on it,
as the others do the same.
Inside,
he discovers a black, futuristic suit
as he sees creepy haired kid already
putting on his.
It's almost as if he knows something
we don't.
All of a sudden,
the crowd is then transported one
by one out of the room
and into a mysterious street
as Kei rushes to put on his suit
before disappearing.
They then see a train track and decide
to go to see which station they are near.
Creepy haired kid then explains
the most insane thing ever and claims
that aliens exist on Earth, and Gantz
has tasked them with capturing them.
And for each alien you kill,
you get ¥10 million.
He shows them his location device,
revealing to the group
the location of an alien, and he sets off.
It's Showtime boys
and whatever the hell that means.
All I know is
that shit is about to go down,
which means I need to leverage
my odds in order to stay alive.
Because what this creepy haired
guy told me is whatever we're up against
probably won't be a walk in the park.
The room had suitcases with suits
made specifically for us, with our own
names on it,
dance or whatever the hell that means
was prepared for us to come here.
And right now we're at a disadvantage
since we lack the context or information
to know what's really going on.
Like a very, very bad game of dodgeball,
we'll have a better chance
if we pick the winning team to go with.
And right now, that team
consists of just creepy haired guy.
He knows what's going on
and even had the foresight
to put on his suit earlier
before anyone else did,
which means he's either
prepared or knows something that we don't.
And at this point,
that's good enough for me.
So I'm going to charm the skinny jeans
right out of this guy
and make him my friend
because I want to live.
Now there's a chance he may screw me over.
Since demonstrations in his character
tell me that he's kind of a dick,
so I bring Kato and Kei
with me to stick with him throughout.
Along with the red haired
girl in the off chance, he screws me.
Well,
then that's what the red haired girl is.
four She'll make for a killer distraction.
The group cautiously sets off,
but this old man
decides he's had enough bullshit for today
and decides to head home.
But once he leaves a crazy lightning,
been from the sky shoots down
and right into the old man's head,
causing it
to explode, expelling his brains
and human pieces all over the street.
No one leaves until Gantz says so.
Elsewhere,
this glasses guy finds the green alien
chilling in an apartment as he comes out
and says green onions are enough for me.
The gang is confused as all hell,
but isn't wasting no time.
They don't realize it yet,
but if they don't
finish the objective in time,
they will all die.
The gang tries to kill the aliens,
but the gun doesn't work,
and the alien sets off in fright,
invading the group as he backflips off
the ledge and lands on his head,
spewing his brains on the pavement
just as Kei and Kato show up.
But this green
alien is tough as hell as he gets up
and runs off with a gang running
after him, passing by other normal people
who are not suited up
and who cannot see Kei or Kato or anyone.
It's almost as if
they are in the afterlife.
Kato demands answers as he falls
the group as they corner the green alien,
just as this blond haired guy shoots
but misses the alien.
But there's aliens. Time is finished
and the gang wants blood.
They finally shoot him at point blank
range as parts of his body get blown off
one by one.
Kato freaks out and begs them
not to kill the alien, but it's too late.
Just then they hear a girl
across the balcony
who yells for her mom, clearly
not seeing any of the gang's members
right in front of her.
Suddenly, this blond guy's face changes
dramatically, his mouth begins to whimper
and his eyes bulge out from his head.
As we find out that he's just been stabbed
and behind him,
we see a big green alien
towering over them.
This alien is much bigger
and is thirsty for blood.
I would like to point out
that this is not the time to mess around.
We got to get our act together.
This gang was given
a short list of the aliens
traits,
including its traits and behaviors,
which means they likely
would have had an easier time
dealing
with this adult version of this alien.
If we just dealt with the child alien
a little more discreetly, as it's obvious
that the adult version of this alien grew
much more angry once it saw its child
brutally massacred Kane
Kato have the weaponry to deal with him,
but at close range,
this alien has retractable claws,
making shorter range encounters
more deadly than one would realize.
I would have first dealt with this
by shooting a center mass
such as the chest or stomach.
If they know what's good for them,
they would try and shoot off his limbs
as soon as possible
as this will cripple argue.
Its most powerful offense
and then after will make him a lot easier
to capture or kill the big green alien
then grabs this yakuza guy by the head
and traps him piercing his skull
with his razor sharp claws glasses.
Guy then fires his gun,
but shoots the Yakuza guy,
instead causing him to explode,
littering his organs all over the floor.
They now have only 30 minutes left.
Everybody freaks out as the green alien
monster cuts
glasses guy's arms off and kills
gray suit.
Guy bodies begin to pile up as gray
suit guy gets back up.
A final time as he fires his pistol,
the green alien then confronts Kato
as he tries to reason with the monster
because he doesn't want to kill anybody.
The Green Monster
then lunges for his throat as Kato
dodges his attacks but falls off the road.
Kei then takes Red-Haired Girl
because that's so typical of him
and runs for their lives.
But suddenly
the green alien is hit by a car,
but the driver can't see who they hit,
nor can they help. And red haired girl
ignored their terrible fate.
They need to run now.
The green alien
is harder to kill than the Terminator,
and he gets back up and chases the duo.
Kei then distracts the green alien
and lures him away from red head girl
Kei, running
at a full sprint and jumps with all of his
might off of a ledge, with his suit
somehow propelling him higher into the sky
than is humanly possible.
Landing without taking any fall damage
looks like their suit has some powers.
OK, this was stupid on their end.
We've just found some invaluable evidence
that while people can't see us, we can
still interact with everyday objects
making us different than that of ghosts.
They literally had the perfect chance
to steal that car
from these unsuspecting people
and could have gained the upper hand
by having a car.
From here,
they obviously could have run him over
again and again and again
till that frickin little shit is dead.
Or for a more effective method,
they could have conducted drive bys
at close range without taking any damage
or being at the mercy of these green
aliens chasing speed, as it looks like
he's pretty much as fast as us on foot,
but not by car.
Humans are so stupid.
The green alien then meatball rolls
down the stairs and tries to kill Cage,
just as Kato appears back from the dead
and arm bars the shit out of him,
which was so frickin awesome
before he makes his suit to give him super
strength and beats
the hell out of the alien subduing him.
Then someone out of nowhere fires
a special gun
and traps the alien,
its creepy haired kid.
And it appears that his suit
has the ability to make him invisible.
Creepy haired kid gives the final honors
to kill the green alien,
but he can't do it.
So creepy haired kid kills the alien once
and for all, but their horrifying journey
isn't over, not even close,
and looks like someone is badly injured.
It's Kato.
The gang realizes that he's critically
injured and on the verge of dying.
Creepy haired
kid says that if he doesn't stay alive
until the end of the game,
then he dies for good.
But if he can stay alive
till the end of the timer,
the game will reset, killing him
good as new
but is not looking too good for him.
And just then,
everybody starts teleporting back
to Gantz, much to the dismay of Kei
and red haired girl who curse the heavens
as they try to wake up Kato
but fail back at the room.
The gang sits in defeat just as Kato
somehow magically teleports back.
He's alive.
Gantz then gives everyone
their scores, providing zero's all around,
except for creepy haired kid Kei and Kato
demand to know more about this world
as creepy haired kid spills the beans
and tells them
that he's been here for over a year
and how if people die in this game?
Gantz
then collects more people from the outside
world to play creepy haired kid, then
says they can all go back to their lives,
resulting in everyone happily
leaving the gas room to wait for the next
death game.
OK, so we need to start studying
on this shit as soon as possible.
This includes learning about things
imperative
to our survival
in a variety of situations,
as who knows in this death game
and where it takes place.
We know one thing for sure,
and that is no matter how much damage
I take in the game, if I can make it back
alive, even barely alive,
then Gantz will make me good as new.
This means that I need to learn
how to stay alive
long enough until the game ends.
The mandatory killing alien part aside,
I think we have a shot at surviving this
if we start now.
This includes
learning a little bit more about survival
tactics and military tactics,
since our group is basically
our own team of soldiers, for example,
learning to attack
from a defensive position,
feigning a retreat,
focusing more on skirmish tactics.
If such a thing is even possible
against these alien bastards,
once the crew leaves the Gantz building,
their lives go back to normal,
including not being invisible to everybody
in the world as if it were all a dream.
But red haired girl wishes it were a dream
as she heads back home
to some devastating news.
Turns out she didn't kill herself
and is now in the hospital
recovering from her attempted suicide,
which means this red haired
girl is now a copy of herself.
Looks like Gantz made a mistake,
and one that will now cost her badly.
Later, K wakes up and finds out,
sadly, that him now being an alien monster
hunter was not a dream
and gets ready for school.
Knowing what
we know that it's only a matter of time
until he's
summoned to play again, the school routine
then goes back into full swing
as K and everyone else
go back to their regular classes
and regular problems.
Glasses Guy complains to K about his
bully problems, but then this bully shows
up, demanding Glass's guide to pay up,
but says that he can transfer his debt to.
Hey, if he wants to,
and unfortunately for Kei,
this is exactly what glasses guy does.
Kei now has until after school
to pay this bully or else after school.
Kei stops by the bathroom
as he tries to calm himself down.
Unless he does something,
he will get beaten to a bloody pulp
by the school's most terrifying bully.
But then his luck strikes again
as he remembers
he brought his Gantz high tech
suit back with him.
He puts his suit on getting ready to meet
the bully.
Had the bully meeting, K
stands quietly as the bullies beat up
another man
who owes them money,
hoping that if he stays silent
for long enough
that he might just escape with his life.
But this bully isn't having any of that,
and he beats Kei to the ground,
beating him so bad
that he starts to go nut .
But his horny brain just won't quit.
And then he begins
to have raunchy thoughts about red haired
girl disgusted beyond belief.
The bully picks up
Kei and is ready to clobber him until Kei,
thanks to his raunchy thoughts, activates
his suit's powers and knocks
this bully out.
What Kei doesn't know
is that his life will now be on the line
yet again in less than a week.
OK, this was the best case scenario,
and frankly, Kei walked the line here
a little bit.
If he had killed this bully,
then this would have only caused
further problems for him down the line.
Think about it.
The charges for murder and manslaughter
are indictable offenses,
which can only be heard
by the District Court or the Supreme Court
and can result in capital punishment
by hanging.
And even if Kei didn't
get the death penalty
through this,
an investigation into this murder
would likely lead back to the suit
that Kei used to murder that bully,
which would have inevitably
led back to the discovery of gas,
which, if the country found out about its
existence,
would have led to Kei's death by Gantz.
Because if we remember, the rules
set by Gantz at the beginning stated
that if anyone finds out about Gantz,
this would be punishable by death.
So he needs to watch how he handles
the public when he has his suit on.
Hey, so 80% of you are not subscribed.
So go subscribe now. See ya.
(IF YOU SEE THIS. PLEASE SUB AND THEY'LL LET ME SEE MY FAMILY - EDITOR ALBIE)
Elsewhere we see a tough biker dude.
Red haired guy
who's playing house with his baby
mama and son as he goes off to buy
some cigarettes and milk for his kid,
not realizing that he's about to die
within a few days back at Kei's House. Kei
returns to find red haired girl waiting
outside and who has a strange request.
Turns out she's homeless
and needs a place to stay.
This terrifies Kei as to the possibilities
that are about to happen,
at least according to his horny teenage
imagination.
Later that night, Kei and red haired girl
lay in bed as Kei tries to be cheeky
and Copperfield, but then all of a sudden
is met with red haired girl.
Sad story explaining to him
how she came to be in Gatz due to her
attempted suicide and is simply too
distraught to be in the mood for anything.
Later in the morning,
Kato and his little brother
sit in punishment at their aunt's house.
This aunt likes to beat children,
and Kato has had enough of her
shit as he threatens her, telling her
to stop hurting his little brother.
Kato needs money
to take his brother away from this child
abusing aunt before it's too late.
The next day, Kei hits the supermarket
with red haired girl,
but he's strapped for cash
until he meets grandma.
The very same grandma who he met
on the subway moments before he died.
Kei then rushes home with red haired girl
and asks her to put on her gas suit
as he thinks that this is a sign
that he'll get a call from Gantz
very soon.
Kei needs to learn how this suit works
before he is sent back in to risk his life
for Gantz?
All right, it's a little bit nuts
that Kei hasn't
figured out how his suit works by now.
Who knows
when Gantz will call them back in?
He needs to get acquainted
with his bio suit ASAP.
If I was him,
I would have coordinated
with the other members in my team
and would have tried
to set up training days.
But we would all come together,
have a good kumbaya
and figure out how the suit works
and its mechanics together.
I would have also worked together
with Kato
to take advantage of this redhead better
for the next game. Hear me out now!
It's obvious that at this point
that red haired
girl isn't attracted to me,
but is attracted to Kato by communicating
with Kato.
That red haired girl just loves him.
We can manipulate the red haired girl
and make her think that she has a shot
with Kato this way.
Her and him would get real close together.
Then by the time
we have the next dance game,
who could use her to do our bidding
and or tasks for us?
While risking her life over OURS,
red haired girl struggles
to put on the Gantz suit, and she asks
K how to use it, but K is scared
to tell her the naughty truth.
So he says that they'll have to find out
for themselves before heading to school.
Meanwhile, Judgment Day has arrived
and the very same grammar from before.
I hate
that woman takes her kid on a day trip,
not realizing that today is the day
that both of them will die at school.
Kato saved this kid from getting bullied
as the bullies themselves get pissed off
and plan to beat Kato up after school
with this bully planning to violate him.
If you know what I mean,
but thanks to one dude informing Kato
about these bullies horrifying plan, Kato
then takes matters into his own hands
and goes into the bathroom himself
later on and absolutely destroys this guy
clobbering his face and with no remorse
or regard for human life.
This isn't the good boy Kato that we know,
and God has made him a changed man,
and it's this level of heartlessness
that Kato will need to use and Gantz soon.
Elsewhere, these two girls
check out this guy Mr.
Stud, who's a famous model
who now has a stalker as he notices
this girl following him.
He then asks these.
Who hard, flustered girls, if he can
borrow their bikes, the girls agree as Mr.
Stud takes off in haste,
not realizing that this bike by tonight
will cost him everything.
I'm sorry,
but if you're a famous, handsome stud like
me and I know everyone agrees that Mr.
Stud himself
should have already been prepared
to combat his stalker
even if she is a tiny little girl.
It's Anna Mae people.
If she's small and tiny,
she's very powerful.
You know what I mean?
I'd personally recommend
my favorite saber red
pepper spray keychain small, compact
and very cute, but also discreet.
And speaking of red peppers,
what Cotto faced was actually
very unsurprising, as bullying in Japan
is actually a very, very big problem,
with a record number of incidents
in a single year
as high as 414,378 cases from elementary
right through senior year high schools.
And this,
like the country itself, has been linked
toward issues regarding conformity.
Meaning if you're taller than average
or prettier
or look different,
then you could be a target.
Hats off to Cotto, but maybe wear a mask
next time just so you don't get caught.
And hey, remember we didn't start
this fight, so we're in the right sorta.
The night of everyone's death has arrived
as red headed biker guy gets ready to
go out and buy milk, not realizing
that tonight is his last night alive .
He heads out and stops by his gang's
chill out spot
as they suddenly get jumped
by a rival gang.
The horror show has just begun.
The rival gang draws first blood as red
haired guy fights for his life, beating
dudes up left and right
as his life depends on it because it does.
At the same time.
On this bridge,
the grandma and grandson
get stuck at the back
of a traffic jam on the highway
and even crosses paths
with motorcycle guy
who stuck right next to them,
and the universe prepares
for what's about to happen.
Suddenly, a truck in the distance
speeds up with this driver
fast asleep at the wheel
as the truck simultaneously gains momentum
and heads straight for Granny Adam Mr.
Stuck just as red haired
guy gets stabbed in the stomach and falls
as his consciousness
withers out of existence.
The truck then slams into Mr.
Start grandma and her grandson,
killing all of them, with Gantz laying
claim to the fallen victims of this night
as everyone dead or alive from before
it gets teleported back into gas.
According to the CDC, an estimated one in
25 adult drivers have reported
falling asleep at the wheel in the past
30 days, with drowsy
driving being responsible for over 91,000
crashes, resulting in 50,000 injuries
and nearly 800 deaths,
according to the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration.
That's a lot of players
for gas to use now.
Realistically, the person with the best
chances of surviving was this kid.
Children, on average have chubbier bodies
and a higher proportion of body water,
so they are more robust to injury.
They're also likely better able
to cope in dangerous situations,
as they would be on average
more relaxed than adults
who will be quicker to understand
when their lives are at risk.
But also,
he was the only one who could have
possibly made it out in time
from before the truck hit.
Grandma's likely way
too dang old and slow to react
at the speeds necessary to stand a chance.
Unless she has a lot of titanium plates
in her old bones,
then maybe she'll survive anyways.
Mr. Stud was trapped on the bike
thanks to that clingy stalker of his
just so y'all know
it's not like the movies.
The oil tanker truck itself actually
wouldn't have necessarily exploded
unless it was nearly empty.
As if we assumed there was gasoline in.
It would have needed oxygen to burn
and a lot of it to cause an explosion.
But of course, kids are stupid.
Everyone appears in the room,
but this time with some new members.
As red haired
guy shows up with his fallen gang,
along with grandma
and her grandson and Mr.
Stud, all the new players mirror how Kei
and Kato reacted when they first came
here, freaking out and demanding answers.
Kato tries to tell all of them
the gist of the situation,
but no one believes him,
especially the biker gang, not knowing
that they'll soon all be at risk of dying
a horrible death.
If they don't get it together quick.
Just then, Gantz
turns on and gives the group
the rundown of their next alien target,
this Suzuki alien who looks harmless
and barely a threat, and the biker gang
laughs it off, thinking this to be a prank
of sorts underestimating their target.
And that was their biggest mistake.
Suddenly, Gantz releases the weaponry
as this excites the biker gang.
The group
then haphazardly begins getting ready
just as Kei realizes
that he left his suit at home.
He starts to freak out
knowing what we already know
that he's dead meat without it.
Red haired
guy starts to believe what Kato is saying
as he suits up,
as he tries to make the others listen.
But Kei, in the background, tries
to be sneaky and grabs
the other gang members shoot to where he
might as well if they're not interested.
But then Kato finds out
that Kei doesn't have his suit
and then pleads
for one of the gang members to lend
Kei their suit.
But none of them agree,
and even creepy haired
kid says that all suits are made
for the individual assigned wearer,
meaning
wearing any suit Kei wears will not work
unless it's his own case .
Face turns white
as one of the gang members tries to shoot
creepy haired kid in the head, but fails
just as he returns the favor,
but this time killing
one of the biker guys spilling his blood
everywhere.
Creepy haired
kid has had enough politeness for one day
and mentions that in Gantz,
everybody is against everybody claiming
that everyone in here
is just a walking corpse.
With an expiration date, especially Kei,
and just then they are teleported by Gantz
to the next game.
OK, so I acknowledge
this is not good, but our odds of
surviving have just gone up exponentially.
We've got a new members who are clueless
as to what's going on, which is great.
We can use that to our advantage.
I would have preyed
on the vulnerable people in this group,
starting with grandma and her kid.
We may as well use the stupid
motorcycle gang, excluding red haired guy.
He's pretty cool.
This would have been
the perfect opportunity to lie to them
about the purposes of the game
and the need for a gas suit.
And this way, during the game,
I could have separated the new members
and use them as bait to lure
the aliens towards us.
We all noticed that the green alien
was more vulnerable when he was distracted
before creepy guy shot him.
So in this regard,
we could use this same strategy
to at least ensure
that we are not the first ones to die
as we tried to catch the aliens
one by one using the new members as bait.
Suddenly, K appears
as he pops into existence
right near the terrifying Suzuki robot,
and it's headed right for him.
They have 57 minutes left.
The alien goes past him
and, to his surprise, doesn't attack him
until he accidentally captures
its attention.
Now coming for him, K runs for his sweet,
little horny life as he finds
the main group nearby,
and the group lays eyes on this very fast,
strong and menacing
Suzuki Alien, who won't stop at anything
until everyone is dead.
The group stands frozen as they don't know
if this wimpy robot
is the only alien,
and we know how that turned out last time.
This alien then gets angry and uses
its supersonic voice blaster, blowing back
everyone and causing the invisibility
factor
of creepy haired kids suit to turn off.
He then tries to shoot the robot
as it hovers
above him, forcing creepy haired
kid to make a run for us
as he turns his invisibility back on.
But this robot is too damn
smart for him and senses
where creepy haired kid is
until the worst thing happens.
Creepy haired kids invisibility
suit has just run out of battery.
He's trapped.
The robot draws nearer to him,
prepared to kill him as creepy haired kid,
then begs for everyone else
up on the bridge to save him.
But red haired guy
then tells him that he needs to repent
for his sins,
for killing his biker buddy earlier .
And if he does that,
then he will save him.
But creepy haired
kid refuses as he makes one last move
and attempts to punch the alien
just as his suitor loses
all of its health.
Creepy haired kid than base for his life
one last time, Kato has had enough.
He jumps down there to save him,
but the robot then screams
at a supersonic pitch,
blinding and deafening him.
Kato then distracts the alien and grabs
creepy haired kid before he is knocked
down by the robot.
Just as Kato
pulls a last stand move and bear hugs
the robot, squeezing the life out of him.
Literally,
as much as I hate this creepy haired kid.
Him being vulnerable
means that he'd make the perfect bait
for any situation from now on,
and also means that the most experienced
member of the game is done
for which is good news for us
since we're the second
most experienced members in this game.
Saving him was necessary
as these robots, while
dangerous,
we're not the most dangerous in the game.
If we can predict that the Gantz game
will use the same rules every time, then
it's safe to assume
that these Suzuki aliens
are not the toughest bad guys
that we have yet to face in this round
as we usually bump into them
towards the end of the game.
This means that the toughest alien
is still out there,
which means we need all the help
we can get, including
having somebody barely alive
to use as a distraction.
I would have done exactly what Kato did,
but not out of compassion or human nature,
but out of calculating tenacity
because we need to be ruthless.
Granny and her grandson
tag along with the other people
and they decide to go home.
But then suddenly this guy's head
explodes,
causing everyone to start running
like their lives depend on it.
Kato, now with a badly injured,
creepy haired kid, wonder why they haven't
been transported back
yet as this guy is running out of time,
but then realizes his fatal mistake
if they haven't been transported back.
That means they haven't
found all the aliens yet.
And to add to the bad news,
creepy haired kid
finally dies as his damaged body
exhales its last breath.
Just then,
the motorbike gang comes back, scared
shitless,
informing the group of what just happened
that they can't leave the area
until they finished the game.
They also realized that grandma
and her kid aren't here,
so they set out to find them
and the aliens
leaving a subtlest k red haired guy
and this biker guy behind.
But this biker guy has other plans
as he aims his lethal gun at both
the red haired guy
and demanding their weapons.
Meanwhile, Kato
and the group finds grandma
and her grandson,
but also find on the loKator
more terrifying.
Aliens headed their way.
Kato then tells the grandma
and her grandson to run as Kato grabs
the robot, squeezing the life out of it
as more aliens try and kill him, killing
one alien and its inner chicken
before his suit gets fully drained.
He's out of health, defeated and weak.
Kato sits there waiting to die
until red haired
chick starts blasting away some aliens,
and they work together
to defeat the group.
They then realize that they need to find
the grandma and her grandson and the rest
of the group before it's too late.
There were more than enough people
in this situation to handle this alien
if they manage their responsibilities
better.
This alien is known as a Suzuki alien,
which is a birdlike organism.
They cannot survive in our environment.
Hence,
why they need to live in a cybernetic suit
in the form of Seiji Tanaka,
for whatever reason, this means
that despite their whole being strong,
their whole was their one weakness.
The gang could have split up
and distracted the aliens from the jump
and then surprised the aliens
by using a four to five man team
to combat it with one Gantz player arm
by the neck, resulting in the Suzuki alien
being unable to move their neck,
effectively limiting their necks,
anatomical range of motion
and preventing them
from shooting their oral energy beam
from almost all directions.
Then the subsequent Gantz players
could have grabbed
a hold of each of the aliens limps,
with another two members
being the ones to squeeze the aliens
hole from the back and front of the alien
body, disabling its ability to fire
its beams from its mouth and arms,
and then being able
to compress the aliens body
without taking damage, squeezing the hole
until the bird alien within dies,
coming out like a bottle of squeezed
toothpaste
elsewhere, K and red haired
guy are led by gunpoint by this biker guy
until they come across a signal
showing the location of some more aliens,
and he shoves Kei into the house
to check it out,
not realizing that this location
may be the location of all of their deaths
if they aren't careful backing
grandma's area.
She has the biggest problem of all her
grandson needs to pee,
and he takes his suit off to take a leak.
Suddenly, more terrifying robots show up,
and the grandma quickly
tells the kid to run.
But as the grandson runs away,
he stops as he hears his grandma's
horrifying screams, causing him to go back
and witness the most savage sight.
It's grandma, but she's covered in blood.
He goes to hug her as they embrace
tenderly in their last moments
before being obliterated by the aliens.
Kato arrives late to the bloodbath,
and he sees the grandmother
and her grandson's blood covered corpses.
They were too late.
Back at Kei's location,
he stumbles upon a hallway
and he hears some noises
rumbling behind the door,
and just then all the doors open to reveal
even more horrifying aliens.
And to add to more bad news,
a new alien emerges from the back room.
The most insane thing that Kei
has ever laid his eyes on this terrifying
monster bird alien.
Oh my gosh, that thing is bigger
than the big prawn of New South Wales,
but we can't rely on the Australians
to help us beat this bird
when they couldn't
even be the emu way back when useless.
No offense, Australia.
But my bet is that this bird's we point
will be like that of those of the aliens
from earlier.
This alien seems to be a modified version
of the Suzuki Alien, and what this does
makes me suspect that this aliens
reliance on external resources to function
normally may be the key to defeating it,
especially if we deduce that the apparatus
flowing into its mouth is its breathing
apparatus, much like our encounter
with the previous robot aliens.
In theory,
we could try gunning it
towards the breathing apparatus
by shooting at it point blank range.
We need to try and disable the one thing
keeping it functioning
within our atmosphere
before this bird tries
to clear the building.
Because once it leaves,
then it will be game over for us
as it'll have the upper hand when it takes
flight.
K was already within grabbing distance
when he held up that bird at point
blank range.
He simply had to blow a hole
through its breathing equipment,
causing its demise in one fatal sweep.
Why didn't he do that
with only a few minutes on the clock?
K tries to muster some courage, but is met
with a shitstorm of a situation,
causing the building to crash
and K to get the hell out of there.
But the horror show isn't over yet,
as this alien blasts out
the door and grabs
this blond guy
tearing his head right apart.
Suddenly grabbing came the process
and flying him high into the sky.
K struggles to try to break free, but
he's no match for this feathered beast.
If he doesn't free himself soon,
then they are all dead.
With eight minutes left to go.
K struggles and struggles and finally
frees himself from this feathered beast.
But it comes at the cost of falling
straight to his death.
In his last moments made freefall,
K busts out his blaster and blows
a hole in this alien a mile wide,
causing him to kill the final opponent
in this death defying game.
He survives the epic fall
and the death game itself, finally
teleporting everyone back to Gantz
for their scores and for their freedom.
But they know what we know
that this horrifying game is in over,
and it's only a matter of time
until their turn to play comes again.
And if you like playing with dirty
Japanese monsters, as much as I like
playing with watches like comment,
let us know what you like.
Then of course, didn't like it.
Don't get to check out the
how to be playlist down below.